es el momento de nuestra revista de
prensa con Marta Moya Marta Buenos días
para ustedes Hola Ángela Buenos días y
vamos a tratar en esta revista un tema
en Estados Unidos bien delicado el
diario del país abre el día de hoy con
un reportaje que vuelve a poner al
fentanilo esta drogas sintética que
además sabemos que es letal en el centro
de una crisis de salud pública advierte
además sobre su venta a través de las
redes sociales conversemos sobre esto si
angelamos destacado una entrevista que
hace el diario el País de México al
presidente de la organización Víctimas
de drogas ilícitas en Estados Unidos que
es un colombiano Jaime puerta radicado
en California Jaime puerta perdió a su
hijo hace tres años luego de que este
comprara a través de la red social
Snapchat una dosis de oxicodona un
opioide que contenía en su interior una
dosis letal de fentanilo que recordemos
es una 50 veces más potente que la
heroína este suceso llevó a Jaime puerta
a crear esta organización Víctimas de
drogas ilícitas en la que bueno dan
herramientas para combatir la adicción
al fentanilo hablan sobre los perjuicios
de esta droga y además transmiten
propuestas de legislación a los
diferentes estados estadounidenses
además lo que hace esta organización es
desmitificar el hecho de que solo los
drogadictos se drogan ya que su hijo por
ejemplo nunca había consumido drogas
hasta el momento en el que a través de
un microtraficante se puso en contacto
con él en Snapchat Y pues le dio esta
dosis que fue letal para él sostiene
Además este artículo esta entrevista
reportajeada del país que las redes
sociales y las drogas pues forman parte
también de ese proceso de identidad de
los jóvenes cuando intentan pues buscar
socializar para ser parte no de las del
grupo de la comunidad su hijo durante la
pandemia se encer en sí mismo dice Jaime
puerta Y a partir de ahí se conectó con
este microtraficante que le vendió esta
pastilla hasta que la encontró un día en
casa inconsciente con las uñas y los
labios azules además se retrata este
reportaje del país que recientemente la
administración para el control de drogas
la DEA ha concluido su operación milla
en las que ha identificado conexiones
directas entre el cartel de Jalisco y de
Sinaloa en México con
distribuidores de drogas que venden
estas estupefacientes traves de redes
sociales en Estados Unidos la operación
concluyó con más de 3.300 arrestos y una
incautación de más de 44 millones de
pastillas de fentanilo Ángela además
recuerdo que nos había hablado Marta
sobre cómo se están fabricando estas
drogas ya Incluso en México esto es
absolutamente descorazonador a pesar de
que Andrés Manuel López Obrador dice que
todo esto parte de China no que también
generado una crisis un poco diplomática
entre Estados Unidos y México pero amlo
dice que china es pues el país origen de
toda esta crisis y si tuviéramos tiempo
que no lo tenemos para hablar sobre todo
lo que hay detrás de La regulación de
las drogas y la normalización no del
consumo Marta vamos a seguir en esta
misma línea con el medio el orden
mundial que hace un análisis en el que
cita también al fentanilo Y así también
es cita también la crisis de la vivienda
y
dice que estos son dos de los
ingredientes que estar comiéndose la
economía y la sociedad Pues en Estados
Unidos primera potencia del mundo Así es
Ángela es un análisis del periodista
Alex maroño que en cuanto al fentanilo
dice que al final esta droga se ceba con
los jóvenes y que fue la principal causa
de muerte entre las personas de 18 a 49
años en 2022 a través de tiktok o
Instagram los narcotraficantes engañan a
los jóvenes vendiéndole otras sustancias
que están adulteradas
un cóctel mortal sostiene este análisis
que ha aumentado en más de 130 por
ciento las muertes por sobredosis en
adolescentes entre 2019 y 2021 para
ampliación Yo diría que nuestros
televidentes deberían entrar al artículo
y darse una buena leída vamos a cambiar
de tema porque avanza el tiempo
rápidamente continúan los Ecos en la
Esfera próxima a Vladimir Putin después
de esta incursión militar que hemos
venido reportando en Francia 24 de unas
supuestas milicias anti Putin en la
frontera en las regiones de belgoroff
qué es lo que dice el Moscú y Times pues
Ángel almas nos plantea que hay
opiniones mixtas entre las voces voces
proclamen sobre lo ocurrido en belgorot
lo que evidenciaría pues que esta
incursión militar de estas milicias
supuestamente anti Putin tomaron por
sorpresa tanto a los funcionarios del
kremlin como a los propagandistas
afiliados al gobierno ruso por ejemplo
destaca que privoying el líder del grupo
Wagner aprovechó la ocasión para seguir
criticando al ministerio de defensa Ruso
y a las autoridades rusas fronterizas
con Ucrania Alexander koch que es un
corresponsal de guerra colaborador en el
periódico consumos calla Prada muy al
final kremlin también crítico como los
militares y la inteligencia rusa
permitieron esta incursión
dimitriever acusó a kiev a la Unión
Europea y Estados Unidos de lo ocurrido
y dijo que las autoridades rusas debían
matar como ratas a estos líderes que
incursionaron en la región de también
cita en que asesores y exmilitares
aliados a Putin también acusan o dicen
que todo esto es una obra de distracción
de kiev tras la toma de bahamut por
parte de Wagner y los medios estatales
rusos como RT por ejemplo Margarita
simonían la jefa de RT dice que se ha
abstenido de hacer comentarios y también
el tema ha estado lejos de las portadas
de los principales medios estatales
rusos Ángela sobre este tema vamos a
conversar con nuestro primer invitado
del día más adelante Marta pero hay un
tema que quisieran por favor que
abordáramos el cierre que no se nos
quede fuera y son los preocupantes datos
que arroja el informe anual sobre la
esclavitud moderna Pues sí Ángela un
informe que se ha publicado hoy en
Londres y que dice que hay 50 millones
de personas en el mundo bajo condiciones
de esclavitud moderna hasta 2021 Un
aumento de 10 millones de personas
respecto a las estimaciones anteriores
las causas estarían con temas de
conflictos armados la degradación
ambiental general o las repercusiones de
la pandemia de covid-19 el trabajo
forzado representa más de 27 millones de
personas en esclavitud moderna el
matrimonio forzado a 22 millones de
personas en esclavitud moderna y que
dice este informe que Corea del Norte
eritrea y mauritania lideran este
ranking pero que también hay países del
g-20 en las esferas de este ranking de
esclavitud moderna como son India China
o Rusia y la responsabilidad de cada
consumidor no lo que nos hace partícipes
de estos crímenes de Marta Muchas
gracias a usted gracias Ángela